le montant dit que vous pensez à renflouer l'
école ne pas renflouer dessus
étron accepté de tomber plus de beaux chiffres
sur la précipitation dans le théâtre d'automne unifier
grand je suis ouais c'est génial alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
avec la précipitation quelqu'un peut-il sortir ou
ouais bien sûr ouais nous en fait  faire une
fête samedi
c'est Pi Sigma moi ou messieurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
excité Je suis excité ici ce sont quelques-unes
des meilleures utilisations non tu vas biper je
dis que nous allons marcher pour leur vie
mais ils '  Je ne vais pas te laisser entrer voici
mon frère as-tu besoin de quoi veux-tu
être ici bonjour prends ta vilaine chèvre
après la maison dans 11 minutes ou tu es
mort
bienvenue en enfer on y va
ou initiation rite de passage nue
nue seconde qui  était le premier président
George Washington monsieur mauvaise boisson qui a
tiré sur John F Kennedy J'ai tort de boire à la
Guantanamo voilà j'y
vais moi-même, ils font juste ça
pour éliminer les faibles cette promesse d'
obtenir des promesses plus étranges doit y aller
par la santé sinon qu'est-ce que t  il
pointe peut-être qu'elle démissionne si vous démissionnez
il y a un autre gars qui ne pourrait pas le pirater
J'ai des relations sexuelles pour la première fois de ma
vie ne soyez pas stupide pour certains parce que les
vrais additionneurs de nombres à toutes les questions
à rencontrer regardez nous avons  Je n'ai rien fait
que toutes les autres fraternités sur le
campus n'ont pas fait question à venir
nous sommes frères et Amazon nous ne sommes pas
frères mourons-
nous frère mourons-nous nous ne sommes pas frères